okay
[Music]
I am here with Christopher Townsend the
visual effects supervisor for Marvel
Studios Captain Marvel thank you so much
for talking about very welcome
we are here in the Frank G Wells
building on the Disney lot and this is
where the magic happens right this is
where some of the magic happens the edit
Suites are out there the directors are
up there sort of everyday we're all
getting together and talking about the
film and how to make it better so there
are so many fun things to tackle in this
film in particular because you have
other world you have aliens you have
superpowers I want to talk a little bit
about Captain Marvel's powers we see in
the very first trailer her binary powers
come to life it's really really exciting
to see but there's so much to that so if
we sort of look at the first shot where
do you even begin to come up with a
concept for what that power is ah it's
uh it's so interesting every time I
start one of these movies I think I have
no idea how we're gonna do this
so you literally start with a blank
sheet of paper in terms of what we can
do you look at the comic books you look
at videogames you look at art you look
at you know you look at all these
different things we have a visual
development department here at Marvel
who works on all the character designs
for all the movies and I think that so
that one of the first things they do is
start amassing all this reference and
start illustrating and drawing up these
sort of these individual ideas in these
frames one of the things that Anna
Bowden and Ryan flack the directors of
the film that what they've brought to
the film is this sort of very
naturalistic feel so what was really
exciting was how do you make a big
superhero movie but keep it naturalistic
and keep it grounded in reality we were
fortunate enough to have the ability to
shoot brie Larson who is Captain Marvel
when she was shooting on a on a on a
test for another film we photographed
her in what we thought was some good
poses and some shooting some photon
blasts and taking into a binary power
and all this kind of stuff and we
started working on the the effects we
started to we we brought that footage
into the into the computer and we took
scans of Breed so that we can do all her
dimensions and photo
of her and we could actually build a
physical CG model or a CG model of her
that then matched her real model her
real real body we track all that to the
photography so that we now have a
digital version of that in the computer
and then we started with simulations and
sort of keyframe are over the top of
Bree and then we started working on
simulations and many many layers and
many months of work just trying to
create the look of trying to find
something which she doesn't look like
she's on fire she can't look you know
she her energy has to feel strong we
can't in we can't go over her
personality so it was really trying to
find all those bits and pieces and then
once you have that idea of what you want
it to look like you guys have put it
through all of those layers and you
start shooting how do you use practical
elements like lights and those sort of
things to help the visual effects
process it's always really tricky of
knowing how much where-where'd you use
interactive light and when don't you and
so one of the things we we desire we had
designed for the set unruhe Fabri were
these big sort of light bracelets that
she wore which is LED panels of lights
on her on her wrists and sometimes we
even put them on her body so that she
could interactively light up the
environment that she was walking through
but also she could light up her face so
a lot of her body is is then digitally
replaced or enhanced but obviously we
want to keep her face and we want to
keep the performance that she's giving
so often it's very useful to have sort
of when she's moving around with her
lights on her wrist that you have the
move the light moving appropriately well
I love it it is very punk rock and then
I have to say this shot is so beautiful
the scroll transformation that we see on
the beach it's really the first time we
get the full idea of what a scroll can
do how do you put together these shots
because clearly there are two actors
playing one role it was interesting it
was one of the first the first thing the
first transformation we did the first
shape-shifting we did and Ben
Mendelsohn's our sort of lead scroll and
when when he sort of turned up on set it
was one of the first things that Anna
and Ryan the directors spoke to him
about like okay
how do we do this how should we even you
know what what does a scroll feel when
he goes through this of this
transformation the shape-shifting is it
painful is it is it easy is it take a
lot of effort and I think so a lot of
that comes from the performance of what
the actor is going to bring to it and so
you know we decided that it yes it does
take a lot of effort it's a very
physiological thing that happens is a
very physical thing that should happen
it's not sort of a day we didn't want it
to feel like a just a morph between two
things or just a sort of a dissolve we
wanted to feel like there's things
happening in the body and one of the big
things that we wanted to do is to use
the grooves in the scrolls face the the
way they've always been Illustrated if
these big grooves and the chin and
they're sort of lines so we really
wanted to use that and have that be sort
of almost splitting apart and then the
other other character sort of bursting
out from from within so you have these
two very distinct shots and you have
this interesting component added to that
which is the movement of the camera it
seems like it must be such a long sort
of painstaking process how many
iterations does a shot like this go
through well there are there are
probably there there are dozens of
people that are working on a shot like
this it only took we had one day to
shoot it the entire sequence and perfect
yeah I know so it's always it's always a
little bit rushed when you're dealing
with light and we tried to we wanted it
was supposed to look like sunrise when
in fact it's sunset because that's the
only time we could get there for the
actual shoot so it's the actual get
somewhat chaotic when you're actually
trying to shoot this and then artists
sit down and then they're starting to
really work on it
so it's probably I think we got to
version 350 or something that we
actually that they were finally
submitting now we haven't seen all of
those versions they've done many
versions internally and that they're
turning things around very quickly
themselves but it's a phenomenal amount
of work that goes into a shot like that
and the painstaking work that goes into
individual you know the hairs the way
her hair grows halfway through the sort
of the the process I said wouldn't be
kind of fun if her hair just starts in a
bun and then just falls down rather than
just growing out of her head so it's you
making it up as you go you know when
you're thinking about it and your your
it's never sort of you don't go in with
a plan of exactly how it's gonna go you
you always you're reacting to what you
see so it's a it's a fascinating process
I have a feeling this next character got
you into a real hairy situation because
it's goose the cat cat actors I assume
have some limitations that human actors
don't how much of goose is visual
effects and how much of goose is your
wonderful cat actor Reggie Reggie well
it wasn't just Reggie so the complicated
thing was there were four cats on set
and Reggie was our hero cat but there
was another cat that was good for being
held and there was another cat that was
good for sitting and so some of the
shots are you know when the cat is
floating obviously it's not real and
because a real cat can do that but there
are other shots where the cat is on
somebody's lap I'm just sitting there
and doing cat things and a lot of that
isn't the real cat either a lot of that
is the computer-generated cat I think
there are about a hundred or so shots in
the movie of the cat and I think 70 of
them are CG so about two-thirds of the
shots are virtual
I've seen this side-by-side shot of the
VFX cat and the real-life cat I
personally cannot tell them apart how do
you tell them apart
one of them's got a collar on so that's
the big tail that's the big tail one of
them has to call it and one of them
doesn't what if you take off the color
mmm gets tricky the whole point right
that's what we're going to do and you
trying to and that was really a proof of
concept just to see you know because
obviously the the challenging thing in
this film is being able to match the
shots so that you can go from the light
the real cat to the CG cat back to a
live cat vector and it's really and you
know we we our job is to never take the
audience out of the moment so we have to
nail that and that was that was
incredibly challenging to get that I
love it through that lens so much and
you guys go see Marvel Studios Captain
Marvel in theaters now